first of all congrats on the show I
think people are really gonna dig this I
have a friend who's been in a lot of
movies and I this is a direct question
for you and when I'm out in public with
him people always come up to him and say
did I go to high school with you like
they can't figure out how they know him
you've been in a movie or two people
might have seen I'm curious does the
same thing happen to you absolutely yeah
is that Lyme did I go to high school
with yes it's more often that than
anything else or it's they're not really
excited to to see you or you get the
feeling that they're not really exciting
too excited to see you they just want to
figure out for themselves if you are
someone that they should know from
something or not right and so it usually
ends up like that did you did you live
on so-and-so Street and you know
Milwaukee no do you ever just say yes
just to like end the conversation I
think I used to yeah when I was younger
but now I've I've learned that honesty
is the best policy you just saying you
know I'm Henry Thomas the guy from et Oh
knew it I'm Henry Thomas the kid from
cloak-and-dagger that is the better
answer you were one of the five people
that went to the theaters to see them
hypothetically I did or becomes on cable
it's a guilty thing you know anyway
we're off on a complete tangent but I
thank you for indulging thanks um
I really I really dug this show and I
really dug that how we just you jump in
there's no wasted time and it's just
well done talk a little bit about the
fact that you do just jump into the show
that there is you know you're not
spoon-feeding you like a set up if you
know what I mean well I think it's an
important characteristic of the show
that it's a family story and luckily
like what 99.9% of us have families and
so when I say sister brother mother
father you can download a whole bunch of
information on that and I think one of
the genius aspects of Mike Flanagan
story is that he takes these ideas we
have about families and then really
explodes them with this concept of
horror and so by the time you're in
invested in the family's story and the
ghosts start to come you really feel for
these people and the way that their
family is being torn apart and I think
because the story plays out the show
plays out on two timelines and we're
watching maybe the same event repeat
itself but it's shown through the
perspective of a different character in
the family and you see oh that's the
puzzle piece that I was missing from the
story before and it's it's it's a slow
reveal but kind of that family drama
wrapped in the horror genre with kind of
a train of suspense all the way through
it makes for a compelling viewing and I
think also the thing about having it in
two time periods is that when you're
seeing the the relationships between
these siblings as adults you're getting
a lot of the context for how these
dynamics developed so I feel like you're
able to jump in because you have you do
get a lot of the the backstory as it's
going on about how much of the arc of
the season did you know did you have
like all 10 scripts going in how much
did you know about the arc we had I
think we had eight when we started Mike
though gave us all our full stories we
he just hadn't published the last two
for us and we were given that gift you
know Netflix is very storyteller
friendly they're very into filmmaking
and so they gave Mike and the entire
writers room the time to create this
story and so by the time we showed up we
knew basically what happened until we
got to the house which is a great luxury
because usually on a show you're you're
seeing the episode for that week and
then you're waiting for the next week's
episode and that would be really
problematic on a show like this because
the the timelines converge all the time
and as an actor it's your responsibility
to keep track of where your character is
in the story cool I already got to go
but I did want to address the long takes
of episode six but that'll be another
time know that what did you think of
that bye um I have my somebody works for
me watch the whole thing I've only made
it to episode four okay but he told me
you need to bring up
six and the three long takes yeah
therefore therefore cuts in the whole
episode yeah I so we rehearsed it like a
play and we shot the episode in two days
you